[Music]  the reason you got interested in it is  through tolkien correct  yes yes that's correct yes because i  read i don't know if this is true and  you might know this daniel but i read  that um  tolkien  drew the maps of middle earth before he  wrote the story  so it came from the languages and the  maps and that's where all this kind of  world  this universe sort of came from is that  true i don't know is it true daniel do  you know i believe it is i believe it  started with uh with his own invented  language and then he created a world in  which that language would  exist and from there  middle earth came and then came  the actual stories that most people know  yeah and the illustrations that um  tolkien  did for middle earth are absolutely  beautiful of course  and that um very  famous middle-earth map that you've  probably signed four thousand times  [Music]  with me and hold me back all through the  night you're shining bright i'm your  boy's the baby you're my pearl